politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans les deux
politiques votre rendez-vous politique
du dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 et pour l'épisode
240 mon invité et ce soir le député des
Yvelines Bruno millienne
[Musique]
vous avez ensuite été réélu une deuxième
fois en 2022 vous êtes aujourd'hui
vice-président de la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire à
l'Assemblée nationale vous êtes très
investi sur les questions
environnementales et énergétiques alors
ces derniers mois d'abord on va vous
reparler encore on a beaucoup parlé de
la réforme des retraites vendredi le
Conseil constitutionnel a donné son avis
sur le texte alors à l'heure où nous
enregistrons cette émission nous ne
connaissons pas encore leur décision en
cas de validation est-ce que cette
séquence des retraites sera
définitivement close pour vous ou pas
non je pense qu'elle sera pas close
parce que toutes les explications n'ont
pas été données après le Conseil
constitutionnel vous avez bien vu les
pressions que les gens essayent
d'exercer sur le Conseil constitutionnel
le conseil c'est Conseil constitutionnel
là pour juger en droit de la validité
d'un texte il n'est pas là pour émettre
une opinion qu'elle soit politique
sociale démocratique peu importe ils
sont là pour juger la validité juridique
du texte donc il s'exprimeront je suis
pas persuadé que il y aura une
validation complète du contexte parce
qu'il y a quelques articles dans le
texte qui sont sujets à caution en tout
cas au niveau de la Constitution et ils
feront leur boulot comme ils l'ont fait
pour tous les textes et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que quand j'entends
un petit peu les chaînes d'infos parler
de du verdict du Conseil constitution
vous avez ceux qui vont dire ah bah si
jamais le constitue le Conseil
constitutionnel donne raison au
gouvernement mais oui mais c'est que des
gens qui ont été nommés par le Président
donc ils sont la seule et puis ils
diront l'inverse et effectivement ils
inventent ils Invalides le texte en
disant ah c'est des sages ils sont
formidables ils ont ils ont ils ont
invalidé le texte donc respectons il
faut absolument respecter les décisions
du Conseil constitutionnel car c'est la
plus haute juridiction de l'État et au
cours de la cinquième république elle a
quand même donné des avis qu'ils étaient
très intéressants et qui étaient
objectivement de bons avis en tout cas
sur le plan juridique donc faut pas
qu'il y ait contestation sur ce que va
donner le Constitution le Conseil
constitutionnel comme avis
à partir de là et quel que soit la
décision ça m'étonnerait qu'on en ait
fini réellement avec l'histoire de la
réforme des retraites pendant ce
temps-là la première ministre Elisabeth
borne a souhaité montrer son ouverture
au dialogue c'est deux dernières
semaines elle a reçu les représentants
des différents syndicales et des
différentes oppositions même sur des
sujets clivants comme celui de la
réforme des retraites on sait que les
discussions la bourrites on aboutiront
pas sur des compromis mais est-ce que
c'est quand même
utile vous modem vous avez longuement
appelé à ce dialogue social juste
d'abord on a longuement à place dialogue
social et puis surtout on l'a pas rompu
c'est tout ça l'important et
si vous regardez bien si on met un petit
peu tout le côté affectif qui tourne
autour de la réforme des retraites en
fait en dehors de l'âge de départ légal
à la retraite qui est un point de
dissensus assez fort ce qui remonte
quand même du terrain quand on écoute
bien les manifestants il faut bien les
écouter ça concerne plus le travail que
la retraite alors vous me direz tout ça
est un briquet en ce sont de comment on
construit sa carrière on a on a une
retraite qui correspond à la carrière
qu'on a construit je pense que il faut
vraiment qu'on travaille sur cette loi
sur sur le plein emploi tel qu'elle est
nommée par le gouvernement mais pour le
coup on a vraiment besoin des corps
intermédiaires on peut pas faire ça sans
eux ça me paraît impossible et je pense
que le modem fera comment dire entendre
sa voix si d'aventure ça devait arriver
alors non seulement il faut que les
organisations syndicales autour de la
table mais il faut l'ensemble des partis
politiques parce que cette loi travail
appelons-la comme ça elle est très
importante justement pour essayer de
gommer les irritants de la réforme des
retraites parce que de la retraite que
vous allez avoir dépend votre carrière
professionnelle et il y a beaucoup de
choses à faire alors le modem soutien
Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 avait fait
partie donc de la majorité
présidentielle baptisée ensemble un
soutien qui n'exclut pas quelques
divergences parfois ensemble ça ne veut
pas dire que un unanimisme qui efface
les identités et les différences à lors
du congrès du parti Édouard Philippe
horizon sur les retraites vous avez été
parfois critiques sur la méthode
employée par le gouvernement est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord aussi pour parler de
crise démocratique non je pense pas que
ce soit une crise démocratique que ce
soit une crise sociale
ça très certainement mais c'est pas une
crise démocratique parce que la
Cinquième République la constitution de
58 a été respectée le gouvernement c'est
servi des outils de la Constitution et
en cela c'est pas une crise démocratique
je vais dire une chose qui va plaire à
personne mais si vous prenez ne
serait-ce que le 49-3 si vous en faites
la lecture telle que l'on voulut Debré
et de Gaulle le 49.3 donc l'article 49
alinéa 3 c'est c'est sûrement
l'article et l'alinéa le plus
démocratique de la Constitution pourquoi
parce qu'il permet de répondre à un
gouvernement qui pense que sa loi est
tellement importante pour le pays qui
l'os braver le Parlement le et la
population donc il engage sa
responsabilité et le pouvoir du
Parlement derrière c'est de poser une
motion de censure pour faire tomber le
gouvernement en disant non la voix du
peuple vous dit le contraire et vous
vous avez perdu son déterminer de ce
gouvernement bon ça c'est l'esprit du
49-3 nous on voulait vraiment voter
exprimer là-dessus on a une vraie
frustration ne pas voir voter pas voir
voter au premier tour parce qu'il y a eu
cette obstruction manifeste des gens de
la nupesse avec ces milliers
d'amendements en particulier de la
France insoumise vous vous souvenez de
l'épisode où Jean-Luc Mélenchon et même
intervenu dans le débat alors qu'il
n'est même plus député en disant non non
non faut pas aller à l'article 7 faut
pas voter
le recul de départ à l'âge de la
retraite moi j'aurais au moins qu'on
voulu qu'on aille là que chaque député
puisse s'exprimer en son âme
inconscience sur le fait qu'on retarde
de deux ans le l'âge de départ à la
retraite ils ne l'ont pas permis donc ça
c'était première frustration deuxième
frustration en retour du Sénat et bien
il y a le 49-3 qui tombe et je suis
vraiment frustré parce que j'aurais
voulu m'exprimer j'aurais voulu que
chaque député en son âme est conscience
prenne ses responsabilités et puis
s'exprimer là-dessus bon ça ne s'est pas
fait
la Cinquième République est bien faite
les institutions sont solides maintenant
c'est dans les mains du Conseil
constitutionnel et on va voir ce qu'il
adviendra de cette réforme des retraites
je voudrais à présent à Bruno Millen
qu'on revienne en 2017 pour revoir un
petit peu les bases de l'alliance entre
donc modem et la République en marche
cette alliance elle reposait sur quatre
piliers principaux une alternance
véritable dans les pratiques et les
orientations politiques d'abord une vie
politique plus moralisée ensuite la
reconnaissance de la valeur et de la
rémunération juste du travail et le
respect du pyralisme politique et avec
une instauration notamment de la
proportionnelle aux élections
législatives alors aujourd'hui six ans
après donc cette alliance a été scellé
entre Emmanuel Macron et François Bayrou
est-ce que vous estimez avoir été
suffisamment loin sur ces quatre points
précis au moins pour la moitié d'entre
eux je veux dire les deux premières
rappeler les mois de alternance
véritable dans les pratiques et les
orientations politiques oui parce que on
sait quand même basé sur quelque chose
qui n'existait pas avant et
on crée plus d'emplois industriels qu'on
en supprime ce qui n'était pas arrivé
depuis 20 ans donc ça les gens le voient
peut-être pas mais notre taux de chômage
aussi bas une économie qui va bien c'est
bien parce qu'on a fait ces cadeaux là
aux entreprises il reste la deuxième
partie qu'il faut qu'on reconstruise ou
qu'on construise ou qu'on reconstruise
plus exactement c'est la partie sociale
et là on a un vrai boulot parce que le
rapport au travail a changé notamment et
ça s'est accéléré avec la crise du covid
les priorités des gens par rapport au
travail sont pas les mêmes moi de mon
temps on s'engageant d'une carrière en
restant dans notre carrière toute notre
vie et puis on se posait pas de
questions et on y allait et a priori bon
ça c'était satisfaisant aujourd'hui les
gens ont besoin de trouver un sens à
l'emploi
vraiment besoin de trouver un sens sinon
ils en changent sinon ils bougent sinon
ils sont même prêts à gagner moins
d'argent mais dès l'instant où il trouve
un sens à donner à leur vie pas
seulement familiale pas seulement privé
mais aussi professionnel donc c'est pour
ça que la loi travail est très
importante parce qu'il faut qu'on
réorganise avec les forces syndicales
cette nouvelle façon d'appréhender le
travail ça c'est le boulot qui nous
reste à faire ça sera sûrement le boulot
le plus social qu'on pourrait faire donc
la deuxième jambe donc c'est pour ça que
j'aimerais qu'on le réussisse et qu'on
le fasse avec les organisations
syndicales notamment j'aimerais
maintenant parler avec vous d'un projet
donc du ministre de l'économie Bruno Le
Maire qui veut faire de la France la
première industrie verte en Europe
il faut des carbonner donc les sites
industriels français l'industrie est
aujourd'hui responsable de 19% des
émissions de CO2 en France alors 29
propositions ont été publiées l'enjeu
c'est donc d'abord de
relocaliser notre industrie on le sait
qui a été délocalisé pendant plusieurs
années 19% des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre pour un pays comme la France
qui ne représente que 1% des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre mondial bien que
les gens et ça en tête quand même
deuxième chose il fallait qu'on aille à
la fois se pari
de l'industrie verte avec le Paris de la
compétitivité alors on sait très bien
que la compétitivité sur le territoire
national c'est pas c'est pas le vecteur
prix du produit final ou du service
rendu qui va nous rendre compétitif on
est battus par les Chinois on est battus
par les Américains on est battu par par
beaucoup de pays en termes de prix
faciale et final donc il fallait qu'il
fallait qu'on trouve qu'elles étaient
les atouts de la France et le premier
atout de la France c'est son énergie
décarbonée il n'y a que deux pays en
Europe qui sont capables d'avoir une
énergie aussi décarbonée c'est la France
et la Suède
à partir de là on a construit pour ce
qui concerne mon groupe de travail
l'idée de mettre en place un standard
pour les entreprises qui est un standard
basé sur le volontariat et les
entreprises sont pas obligées de le
prendre ne sont pas obligés de demander
à certification qui s'appelle excellence
environnemental européenne dans lequel
on va rentrer une trentaine j'ai pas le
chiffre exact mais en tout cas pas plus
de 30 normes environnementales
économiques les moins contestés ou les
plus incontestables au monde
qui sont facilement appréhendables par
les entreprises
et on va rajouter deux choses en chapeau
de de ces normes-là c'est un bilan
carbone un peu simplifié pour les TPE et
PME parce qu'il est un peu compliqué et
surtout
l'analyse du cycle de vie
parce que l'analyse du cycle de vie ça
permet de pondérer le prix du produit en
fonction du coût carbone
qu'utilise la manufacture de ce produit
et là pour le coup on devient très très
compétitif
et comme c'est un standard qui est
volontaire qui va tenir compte à la fois
de la taille des entreprises du temps
qui leur faudra pour celles qui
décarbonent ou encore du secteur on
pense bien embarquer toutes les
entreprises on compte bien aussi
récupérer les financements verts qui
aujourd'hui sont un peu perdus il y a
beaucoup de gens qui veulent investir
dans la Green tech on va appeler ça au
sens large et la décarbonation sauf
qu'ils sont pas persuadés que les
entreprises sur lesquelles ils
investissent sont des entreprises qui
font vraiment de la greinthèque ou de la
décarbonation ils ont peur du
greenwashing avec ce standard là c'est
la garantie que leurs investissements
seront respectés il n'y a pas
d'incompatibilité entre la croissance
industrielle et la transition écologique
contrairement contrairement aux écolos
qui prônent la décroissance
nous on est persuadé qu'on peut avoir
une croissance qui sera sûrement moins
importante on va pas se mentir on va pas
les croissances à deux chiffres c'est
terminé on peut avoir une croissance
raisonnable qui fasse aussi le virage
écologique énergétique dont on a besoin
une concertation donc est organisée les
acteurs économiques sont invités à
donner leur avis jusqu'au 24 avril c'est
toujours dans cette optique d'ouverture
au dialogue et de co-construction ce qui
est promu en tout cas par votre partie
le Mouvement Démocrate mais ça me va
bien parce que ce qu'entrepris Bruno Le
Maire en fait avec ce projet de loi
c'est un petit peu ce qui avait été
entrepris pour la loi pacte qui a
beaucoup débloqué l'économie alors on
l'a fait de manière un petit peu plus
resserrée on va atterrir sur un texte
moins grand moins lourd moins gros que
pacte mais pour plus d'efficience et
c'est effectivement comme ça qu'il faut
qu'il travaille alors le projet de loi
il devrait arriver à l'Assemblée
nationale environ au début de l'été
quels sont encore les points de
négociation les points qui qui sont en
discussion sur ce qui concerne mon
groupe de travail qui sera sûrement le
groupe de travail il y aura le plus de
commentaires donc le moins de légistique
on continue on continue le travail
travail encore danse qui nous reste à
faire notamment sur l'écriture du
standard qui va être pas simple mais on
va s'entourer des gens qu'il faut pour
le rendre compréhensible et efficient
pour les autres groupes de travail sur
la partie financement on va y avoir
sûrement des trucs légistiques sur la
partie territoriale aussi donc tout ça
les consultations continuent nous on
continue à travailler ici de notre côté
mais pour le côté plus réglementaire et
le tout est d'arriver à une espèce de
consensus général sur le texte qui va
nous permettre je l'espère de le faire
passer dans les meilleures conditions
possibles j'aimerais revenir à présent
sur une proposition de loi qui vous a un
petit peu agacé la semaine dernière les
écologistes ont pu présenter lors de
leur niche parlementaire plusieurs
propositions de loi c'est celle de votre
homologue député de Paris Julien Bayou
député écologiste qui souhaitait
l'interdiction des vols en jette privé
vous avez donc évidemment voté contre
cette proposition de loi pourquoi parce
que j'aimerais que les écologistes
fassent de l'écologie qu'il ne s'arrête
pas juste au symbole alors je comprends
bien que les jets privés c'est un
symbole d'ailleurs on va pas rester sans
réagir on va augmenter les taxes
notamment sur les carburants pour
limiter les vols en jet privé mais je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure la France
c'est 1% des missions de gaz à effet de
serre dans le monde les jets privés sur
l'activité aérienne française c'est
0,07% des missions de gaz à effet de
serre autant dire peanuts l'aviation
mondiale globale tout confondu ces 3%
des émissions ce qu'il faut faire des
efforts ailleurs ça que vous bien sûr
comme je l'ai dit dans l'hémicycle je
n'ai aucune proposition des écologistes
sur la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments aucune rien je n'ai aucune
proposition des écologistes sur le
transport routier rien je n'ai rien sur
l'industrie voilà on va voir comment ils
vont réagir sur l'industrie verte mais
je n'ai aucune proposition leur seul
proposition c'est d'interdire on a
essayé avec Delphine bateau sur une
proposition de loi qui était la
proposition de loi sur l'interdiction
des panneaux de la publicité lumineuse
on a transformé un peu le texte pour
essayer d'avancer plus vite dans
l'efficience notamment sur la pollution
lumineuse nocturne et bien parce qu'elle
n'avait pas obtenu gain de cause sur
l'interdiction elle a retiré son texte
donc moi cette écologie de
l'interdiction je ne la comprends pas
c'est vraiment un concept
qui n'est pour moi n'a rien à voir avec
l'écologie franchement il faut qu'il se
remette en question
[Musique]
toujours avec Bruno millienne député de
la 9e circonscription des Yvelines et
porte-parole du MoDem alors dans la
situation régionale la situation ne
s'arrange pas sur le plan de la
sécheresse en tout cas dans le
département des Yvelines à certains
endroits du département le niveau des
nappes phréatiques et exceptionnellement
bas pour la saison et ce malgré donc les
pluies du mois de mars au niveau
national le gouvernement a présenté un
plan o l'objectif donc réduire de 10%
les prélèvements en eau d'ici 2030 pour
inciter les Français une tarification
progressive de l'eau pourrait être mise
en place est-ce que c'est une bonne idée
selon vous dans les bonnes idées la
première des bonnes idées qui aurait dû
être faites depuis longtemps et j'en
veux au grand groupe je suis désolé de
le dire mais dans la facture d'eau que
vous payez vous et moi il y a une partie
de taxes qui est pour l'entretien des
réseaux
or un cinquième de l'eau potable que
vous avez robinet part dans la nature et
pour moi ça c'est juste inconcevable
nous tous citoyens nous payons pour
l'entretien des réseaux et l'entretien
des réseaux n'est pas fait donc il va y
avoir un gros effort de fait je crois
que le gouvernement va mettre plus de
100 millions d'euros sur la table pour
l'entretien des réseaux ça c'est
première chose deuxième chose qui est
une aberration en France mais bon voilà
c'est comme ça et enfin on va s'y
attaquer c'est qu'on n'utilise pas l'eau
recyclée on ne recycle pas notre eau je
vous rappelle 80 plus de 80% 90% en
Israël alors évidemment
Israël n'a pas pu faire autrement parce
que de l'eau potable ils en ont pas mais
malgré tout on aurait pu se poser la
question avant et même pour nos
agriculteurs c'est important vous prenez
vous prenez par exemple une station
d'épuration qui reverse l'eau
l'eau qui a été traitée dans la rivière
qui passe à proximité si vous avez un
agriculteur qui est au bord de la
rivière aujourd'hui il n'a pas le droit
de prélever or c'est un flot continue il
pourrait très bien prélever 10 à 15%
sans aucun problème pour ses cultures
donc ça il faut qu'on travaille
là-dessus je vous prends un autre
exemple si vous avez
[Musique]
les bassines notamment sainte Soline
donc ça suffit maintenant même dans le
rapport du GIEC il est marqué qu'il va
falloir qu'on fasse des retenues
colinaires enfin donc des retenues d'eau
on a des milliards de mètres cubes d'eau
qui tombent du ciel et qui partent à la
mer il faut qu'on les récupère parce
qu'on va être en plein stress hydrique
donc tous les moyens qui sont bons pour
récupérer l'eau en faisant attention à
ce qu'on fait bien évidemment il faut
qu'on le fasse et qu'on sorte des dogmes
hallucinant moi je ne connais pas
d'agriculture qui existe sans eau ou
alors faudra qu'on m'explique sur le
recyclage des eaux usées aussi
actuellement en France 1% c'est ce que
j'ai des os et sont donc recyclés
l'objectif c'est d'atteindre 10% en 2030
comment atteindre justement
ça me paraît peu mais quand vous
regardez c'est un gros effort ben je
vous le dis il y a déjà dans l'industrie
beaucoup
recycle l'eau en interne et la
reminarylise pour la rejeter dans les
rivières bah déjà quand les autorise à
utiliser leur recycler déjà on aura fait
un grand en avant il faut qu'on voit
peut-être dans la construction comment
on construit les maisons de demain enfin
pour l'arrosage du jardin pour vos
toilettes pour la douche pour le
lave-linge pour le lave-vaisselle est-ce
que vous avez besoin d'utiliser de l'eau
potable non
travaillons là-dessus enfin tout ça et
petit à petit on va y arriver alors moi
au départ je suis un peu d'ici je me
disais on passe de 1 à 10 % quand les
Espagnols sont à 70 et les Israéliens 90
il faut bien qu'on commence c'est déjà
un
bonbon en avant vous avez beaucoup aussi
travaillé sur le sujet des zones à
faible émission
le 1er janvier 2023 les 11 plus grandes
villes françaises interdisent donc à la
circulation des véhicules qui sont
classés étiquetés critères 4 et 5 alors
dans deux ans toutes les villes de plus
de 150 000 habitants devront mettre en
place ce dispositif les opposants à ce
projet dénoncent une entrave à la
liberté de circulation des zones donc
d'exclusion sociale pour ceux qui n'ont
pas les moyens
d'acheter une voiture moins polluante
qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez je
réponds d'abord que c'est une question
de santé publique parce que c'est pas
une entrave c'est une question de santé
publique 45000 heures par an 48 000
morts par an à la pollution à cause de
la pollution atmosphérique ça ne peut
pas durer comme ça c'est pas possible
alors après je comprends les inquiétudes
et c'est bien pour ça que je me suis mis
de sur ce sujet avec autant de
convictions parce que je veux qu'on y
arrive d'abord faut que les gens aillent
dans la tête que le couperet tombera pas
en 2025 mais le coup pré final c'est
2032 c'est là qu'on jugera sur toutes
les agglomérations qui doivent déployer
des ade si elles sont à l'intérieur des
normes de l'OMS ou pas
sur les 43 nouvelles agglomérations qui
ont été annoncées par le ministère il y
en a déjà 9 dont j'ai pas les noms je
suis désolé mais il y a un januf qui
n'auront pas besoin de déployer deux ZFE
parce qu'elles sont en dessous des
normes de l'OMS donc c'est plutôt pas
mal pour celles qui sont encore au
dessus on est juste au dessus donc il y
a du travail à faire ensuite pour les
vignettes critères 4 ou 5 on a alerté le
gouvernement le gouvernement a commencé
à travailler avec les collectivités pour
avoir une harmonisation des
interdictions et pour voir comment on y
arrive
là où la marché haute 4 et 5 on peut y
arriver la marge commence à être haute à
l'interdiction des critères 3 et encore
plus haute là où vous irez à
l'interdiction des critères 2 et pas
évident qu'on arrive jusque là qu'on ait
besoin d'aller jusque première chose
deuxième chose je me bats je suis pas le
seul mais je me base c'est un de mes
combats pour que on trouve les moyens de
fournir aux gens qui vont se retrouver
pénalisés les moyens de pouvoir circuler
dans ces ade en leur proposant des
véhicules
qu'ils puissent utiliser et qu'ils
puissent acheter ou en tout cas utiliser
que ce soit en LOA par exemple en
location avec option d'achat ou en
location longue durée de manière à
pouvoir continuer à circuler on est sur
un dispositif aujourd'hui qui s'appelle
rule qui veut utiliser ce qu'on appelle
les véhicules hors d'usage mais qui sont
roulants et qu'on va rétrofiter au GPL
au bioéthanol ou à l'électrique et on
aura un leasing pour GPL et bioéthanol
qui sera 80 euros par mois sans problème
la majoration du premier loyer ni le
problème de la réparation du véhicule au
bout de 5 ans puisque ce véhicule
retournera là où il aurait dû être dès
les premiers jours c'est à dire à la
casse donc déjà on offre cette palette
là pour les gens qui ont le moins
d'argent possible je suis en train de me
battre pour qu'on trouve toutes les
solutions possibles pour les gens voilà
il y a pas de raison on va y arriver moi
l'interdiction du critère 2 je la vois
pas tout de suite même pas du critère 3
vous avez vu qu'en métropole du Grand
Paris ils ont renoncé pourquoi parce que
s'ils enlèvent le critère 3 aujourd'hui
d'accord et bien c'est 2 millions 700
000 véhicules qu'il faut trouver en
remplacement sachant que le but n'est
pas de remplacer un véhicule par un
véhicule mais admettons or en produit un
million 400 000 véhicules neufs par an
chercher l'erreur donc là encore une
fois principe de réalité mais ce combat
contre la pollution de l'air est
essentiel pour nous et pour nos enfants
pour finir je vais aussi avoir votre
avis sur le travail du Président du
Conseil départemental de l'Essonne qui
travaille pour la création de voix de
bus express et de voix dédiée aux
covoiturage pour justement que la grande
raison des servent mieux soit mieux
desservie par le pour le Grand Paris
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez et la
raison regardez nous sur le département
des Yvelines à 14 Express souvenez-vous
quand ça a été lancé il y avait un aller
le matin un retour le soir aujourd'hui
un aller-retour toutes les heures voilà
et les bus sont plein il y a pas de voix
réservée donc ça marche le covoiturage
les plateformes de covoiturage ont fait
énormément d'efforts ils ont compris que
pour avoir des covoiturés
il fallait jamais bouger le trajet du
covoitureur parce qu'il va pas aller se
déplacer pour aller chercher les gens je
vous prends de l'exemple de deux
sociétés il y a classic et ecove je
crois qui ont mis ça en place elles sont
c'est prêt-à-forme sont rémunérés par
les collectivités d'accord le
covoitureur et rémunéré le covoituré lui
voyage gratuitement et ça leur coûte
moins cher que de mettre en place un
réseau de bus donc il y a énormément de
solutions sur les territoires qui
existent il faut les faire remonter les
faire converger faire en sorte d'abord
que toutes les collectivités se parlent
pour qu'il y ait un écosystème qui se
crée et qui facilite la mobilité des
gens mais c'est ça la mobilité demain
alors ça paraît lointain ça paraît flou
pour les gens mais je peux vous assurer
que ça existe c'est réel et qu'on va se
battre pour le mettre en place partout
merci beaucoup merci à vous d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle donc que vous êtes
député des Yvelines et porte-parole du
MoDem et nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
l'hebdopolitique sera de sensations et
sur TV 78 très bonne soirée à tous
et aux politiques